and welcome to hannity reporting from
dallas tonight and coming up fbi boss
christopher wray grilled on capitol hill
about hunter biden political bias and
public corruption at some of the highest
levels of the fbi plus a frequent cnn
columnist just proclaimed that donald
trump supporters are no different than
the terrorists of al qaeda oh i guess so
much for the new era of journalism under
the new fake news boss this guy chris
licht at fake news cnn
maybe it's time for him to go back to
stephen colbert where he came from and
later tonight new york is going from bad
to worse as the city refuses to lock up
repeat offenders all in the name of
social justice now many residents are
forced to take matters into their own
hands we're going to talk to one local
boxing and mma mma coach left into
action against the violent criminal but
first we begin tonight with a common
theme from the biden white house and
that is one of weakness take a look
i must admit in total disclosure i've
i've spoken to the chairwoman about the
possibility of my being able to buy one
of those corvettes that are electric
vehicles
that uh you know when they come out
i'm not gonna be able to do it because i
can't drive a vehicle while i'm vice
president while i'm president it's good
for the economy and the environment
well thank you
is it alright if i ask a question
brian of course mr president i was going
to just turn briefly uh before we get
our other speakers to just ask uh
secretary ellen to offer
um
before you do can i ask you a question
sure of course i'd like to ask a
question
you can't make this up anyone with a
pulse can see that joe biden is
physically mentally just gone out of it
completely now his naive policies are
even worse now joe seems to think he can
save the world with a massive amount of
new taxes and federal spending 87 000
new irs agents we're going to more than
double the number of irs agents and then
of course everybody needs an electric
car he also apparently believes the
world peace that that can be achieved
through appeasement now sadly this kind
of weakness always always invites
aggression last year biden attempted to
appease the taliban remember gifting
them pogrom air base air force base to
allow them to march right to the center
of kabul in record time in just a few
months kabul is already a safe haven for
al qaeda the terrorists are honored
guests of the taliban and let's not
forget when biden tried to appease
russia you know that shiny new nordstrom
2 pipeline and then putin immediately
what does he do in return he invades
ukraine and biden's diplomatic efforts
with russia are such a disaster that
he's totally failed to even be able to
free wnba player brittany griner who is
now rotting away in a russian prison
cell because of what a weed pen
nine years in jail and joe's words to
vladimir putin are completely
meaningless now this all despite
offering up so-called merchant of death
remember this guy we told you about in a
prisoner exchange now this narco
terrorist and international arms dealer
was convicted in a plot to kill
americans america's relationship with
russia is at its lowest point since the
cold war and sadly we're also seeing the
exact same thing unfold with communist
china and tonight it is clear that the
ccp wants to invade our ally taiwan
china's military has been conducting
live fire drills just off the coast of
taiwan chinese fighter jets perpetually
seemingly breaching taiwan's airspace
they are firing missiles now over taiwan
and the ccp now just threatened to
assassinate the speaker of the house
because she dared to visit the island
and our ally and this of course after
uh president xi was lecturing and
threatening joe biden and he did nothing
the joe biden challenge president xi
on on covid and the lies of china no he
did not to the extent he needed to
intellectual property theft nope unfair
trade practices no treatments of the
minority uyghur community nope flying
jets over taiwan no joe got lectured by
president xi not the other way around
now any conflict between china and
taiwan would cause a mass casualty
situation wreak havoc on the global
economy already struggling joe biden is
doing nothing to deter any of china's
aggression instead he's trying to
appease communists with tariff relief
why would you benefit china at this time
and you know naive words about one china
even tried to distance himself from
nancy pelosi's trip to taiwan and just
deployed an important u.s missile test
this is beyond pathetic it won't work
and probably it's going to incur more
aggression as we go down the road
according to a new report china is now
prepping for a possible invasion of
taiwan before the 2024 election yet joe
biden won't even pick up the phone have
a tough conversation with his old friend
president xi our very own peter ducey
asked about all of this earlier today
take a look at this exchange president
biden's known him for
decades
he's got a lot of free time up there in
the residence this week he doesn't have
free time he he's he's he can't just
pick up the phone and call been working
all the way through his illness quite
frankly peter so that's a little bit
insulting and um as for a call
it is
that someone who is isolating by himself
you suggested he has a lot of free time
as if he's not doing anything and you
know that's not the case mr ducey
you would think china might be at the
top of the priority list now biden never
really has much of anything on his
schedule we all know that we know he
wakes up late goes to bed early so i
guess it's fair to say biden does very
little in the oval office or in the
white house hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else